one of the uh the catalysts or you know
to why we're
having this number three right now is
because
prior to the pandemic uh and i've shared
all this
stuff with you michael but you know um i
was
i was in the process of writing a book i
mean i was in a
much better place than where i was three
years ago as i've shared with uh with
you and the listeners
um i went through a whole breakdown
three and a half
years three and a half ish or so years
ago when i first moved out to austin and
just
uh didn't realize how much i didn't love
myself or or feel any self-worth at all
and i did so much work and went to
incredible therapy as a place of privacy
swiss as we've talked about and
with those amazing people yeah and um
and shazam comes out of that and
marvel's mrs mazel and all of these
things just
felt like okay i've done the work and
i've healed of this thing and now look
at the
fruit of that labor and i'm good i'm
good now and i didn't realize just how
ungood
i was i didn't realize just how little
healing i had done
uh and amazing by the way it's it's an
incredible i think example and testament
to god's love
even a little bit of work that we do can
bring about such incredible growth and
such incredible things
but i still had so much more to do and i
didn't realize it until the pandemic hit
when i fell apart i come i crumbled and
when it when it first started i was
actually okay and i felt optimistic
and then once the country started
ripping apart at the seams
and there was just all of this vitriol
and all like we're
so and as an empath like not only did i
feel all that and feel like what is
like i lost hope like what is the point
of even working toward all these things
we're working toward if everybody's
going to hate each other at the on the
other side of this and
um and also me just you know all the
negative
loop that we find ourselves you know uh
um these lies that stay in our head and
we can't get out of our head like you're
worthless or you're you're
dumb or you're not or you're ugly or
whatever all of the things
and um and this was i was in the process
of writing a book
because harper collins had hit me up and
they were like listen we really want
to we want you to write a book about
your mental health journey specifically
this one that i've talked about many
times before
you know kind of um the the the
going away to this healing therapy
retreat
and then becoming a superhero on the
other end of that like
you know this um a really powerful
uh part of what my you know very long
mental health journey
has been